l'environnement faut-il imaginer un
monde sans abeilles
les mois passent et le constat se
confirme en france comme en europe et
sur tous les continents
elles disparaissent de manière
inexpliquée et dans des proportions
inquiétantes pourquoi s'en préoccuper et
bien notamment parce que la plupart des
plantes à fleurs dépendent d'elle pour
la pollinisation pour les apiculteurs ce
sont les pesticides qui sont en cause
reportage laurence de chef marie cros
est capable de voler le volet c'est pas
normal
les apiculteurs ont un problème leurs
abeilles ne reviennent pas à la ruche et
meurent de façon inexpliquée cette année
en provence 30 professionnels viennent
de subir d'importantes pertes et pour
eux pas de doute et reçus sont superbes
vous voulez porter sur la lavande vous
repassez 8-10 jours après vous n'avez
plus personne dans les os tout les
butineuses sont mortes à 90 chaînes sur
scène c'est un traitement sur les
végétaux sur lesquels on était là dans
le chocolat c'est la lavande en vendée
cet été sept mille ruche auraient été
intoxiqués par des pratiques illégales
d'épandage de pesticides 50 apiculteurs
porte plainte en france le gaucho et le
régent 2 insecticide qui enrobe les
semences de tournesol et de maïs ont été
interdits en 1999 mais c'est insuffisant
selon les apiculteurs
pourtant il existe aussi d'autres causes
de mortalité comme le changement
climatique les parasites ou les virus
ces facteurs peuvent agir soit
indépendamment les uns des autres mais
aussi en conjonction est dense car on
pense aux interactions entre les
maladies et les polluants de
d'un autre côté les polluants peuvent
affaiblir les abeilles de façon à ce
qu'elle soit plus sensible aux maladies
mais d'un autre côté les maladies
peuvent affaiblir aux abeilles de façon
à ce qu'elles soient plus sensibles aux
polluants comme d'autres pays européens
les états unis aussi sont touchés de la
floride à la californie presque tous les
états subissent des mortalités jusqu'à
50% de leur cheptel
ici les pesticides sont répandues par
avion sur des surfaces gigantesque et
pourtant les agriculteurs ne peuvent se
passer des ruches l'abeille féconde les
fleurs en transportant le pollen
c'est la pollinisation et la fleur
deviendra fruits je voyais une amende
être sûr qu'une abeille de visiter pas
besoin d'avoir fait de grandes études
pour comprendre ça n'allait pas d'âme
ans si les abeilles domestiques
disparaissent les abeilles sauvages aux
6000 espèces d'abeilles peuple la france
vingt mille dans le monde
elles sont toutes nécessaires à la
pollinisation sans abeilles ce sont les
melons qui disparaissent les frais les
courgettes les carottes ou encore les
poires ça va se traduire au point de vue
de l'agriculture par des rendements plus
faibles et une qualité des produits
beaucoup plus fait vous imaginez on va
pas s'amuser à polliniser 1 ha de
pommiers à la main et au niveau de
l'environnement ça va se traduire par
des changements majeurs puisque je veux
80% la flore et pollinisées par les
insectes et principalement par les
abeilles quand les abeilles
disparaissent les apiculteurs aussi en
france on en compte 1500 en moins pour
une production réduite à vingt mille
tonnes au lieu de 30
les i